Trey wants to know what situations do
you find yourself most comfortable in
Trey this is a great question you know I
loved it when Steve brought it up like
hey you want do this question of course
this is like a humble brag question you
know uh you know I mean whoa where am I
most awesome you know listen the thing I
take most pride in is I'm probably be
probably best when it's chaotic and I
think a lot of people fold in that sense
but to me I take enormous pride but I
don't know is I'm really great in
chaotic non-threatening I'm being very
honest here cuz i don't i want to
disguise this humble brag with a little
humility because of how i'd like to roll
you know I uh I'm great in business when
we're real trouble like I'm great that's
my my world I'm really good when people
are upset you know like a kid in my
class died in a car accident senior year
and like i like i was proud in the way i
helped a lot of people i'm really strong
emotionally what I'm not sure about is
if like somebody came up and punched my
wife in the face like what would I do
like you know I'm such a lover not a
fighter that I always questioned myself
in that moment I actually think I come
out guns blazing but that's never really
happened but I'm most comfortable in
chaos as a matter of fact and people can
tell you this in the office these guys
can mention it when you see this stuff
I'm like rolling my ring in this show I
hate quiet and standard I like walk into
vaynermedia everybody's got their
headphones on I can somebody play some
music like all this is like way not
enough for me my wife actually like it
keeps making fun of me because the other
day I somehow said something like New
York's too slow for me she's like shut
you know like like I I'm best when
there's a crapload going on
you